cette prêt pour l'interview réaction en
chaîne moi non
moi non je ne fais pas interviewer
réaction aux jeunes enfants
non monsieur on se concentre mon petit
ramsey que je vous kiffe thiery vous
savez je sais on vous propose un plan à
trois qu'est ce que j'ai fait
on ne viendra me dire on prend la mienne
oui on a déjà joué là bas elle est bien
voilà j'avais des problèmes si je suis
fan
une femme superbe coucher avec vous car
avait une chambre d'hôtes il dit
je profite bredouille chez lui
allez je serai alors après midi moi tu
veux je laisse la nature en addition qui
décide où il est moins bien plus garder
une femme superbe coucher avec vous car
elle vous prend pour gad elmaleh qu'est
ce que vous faites gagne et le mal est
arrivé calme-toi pas là ça devenait
difficile parce que physiquement on a
pas c'est pas super proches n'ont qu'à
des le mal et nous mais disons moi j'y
vais quand même
moi aussi j'ai eu un malentendu c'est
bon si et après je lui conseille un
opticien une femme superbe coucher avec
vous elle vous propose même un million
d'euros personne ne saura jamais ce que
vous êtes d'accord moi je pense que ma
famille regarder non non on est là dans
le choix de me coucher pour de l'argent
oui c'est vrai il n'ya même pas besoin
de dire une femme superbe
il n'est pas normal mais il me dira avec
20 millions d'euros à son avis moi ces
derniers temps c'est devenu taux
maintenus tout par des baisses que nous
le monde y était mais puisqu'il faut que
quatre boutons 3g trop incroyable au
carré
carré blanc au bec fin et on savait
décision dans le divan je n'avais pas si
on allait réussir va vous envoyer en
vacances ensemble et je te donnerai
journée les 200 francs moi je lui
trouvais les francs il voit la plus
riche que je prends je te rendrai jamais
ton argent je sais qu'il va me faire
mais je rendrai jamais tyler avait le
profil pour être animateur à la télé tu
te rendrai jamais été si on continue on
veuille me rendrai pourriez me faire
basile moi un truc
ouais
[Musique]
c'est pas gentil
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quel état ils m ont promis leur garde
maintenant vous battez pas vous battez
pas là bah ouais ben là c'est là c'est
la mienne il est là quand vasile digne
ils regardent et au diabète chez
papa-maman vouliez permis qu'attachante
pertes un ultime jet de l'eau alors
c'était vrai
as events j'amène le talent puisque je
m'excuse mais je m'excuse j'ai été nul
sur ce coup là si tu fais un poutou
s'excuser fais gaffe tu vas te faire un
coup de trace grâce à norman alors à
financer gamme tekna foot ou un vrai de
vrai non je veux regarde ce qu'ils
pensent je veux une remise une remise de
chèques c'est parce que je veux dire ça
veut dire poser mais pas de bruit pas de
bruit pas de bruit et un petit mot
gentil on a les yeux à nous je fais ça
c'est vrai que l'arabie islam modéré
comme audiard
non après le message non le message tu
que je te vois tu vas samassa action
action sur mon gentil action messages
gmail labs ont lâché hubert pas bien
pour la date de ma mère je suis pas bien
là réside ya des trucs qui te plaît
nous devons nourrir le message il va
dire le message pourquoi accès aux
actions djamel message qu'est ce qui est
à dieu passe assez rare n'est pas un
perdreau assez bien voilà c'est bien
rasé il faut tourner à volonté amel on
pleure oui pour qu'il me dise manoir
saint céré lot c'est c'était le meilleur
comique du monde toi le meilleur comme
du monde du web
installez vous monsieur le ministre
[Applaudissements]
islam cela modérés y clame intempestifs
progressiste c'est un beau un beau
message de l'islam sympa parce qu'on a
toujours l'image de l'islam
weedon du faux et cela en fait un de
l'islam agressif de l'islam barbu et
tout est là il ya l'islam classe moi
j'aime bien voir un verbe moi qui suis
catholique super je trouve ça génial
[Applaudissements]
c'est c'est de loin avec eux que j'ai
pris le plus de plaisir à la télévision
je sais que les vacances en forêt dense
et et les vacances ça m'embête c'est
mignon catholique super une femme
visionnaire
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
bisogno mais c'est le mais c'est le
principal c'est ça le pire c'est que moi
je connais que ça sonne allemand qui
suis catholique super ouais je connecte
des islams d'où des islams bisounours d
islam se claque fulham en costard avait
ouvert en maître l'islam à la mode mais
tu sais le concept que je voudrais
océans sont toujours là le truc que
j'aurai lancé le concept de justin
bieber que tous les beurs tous les
rebeus de france qui se reconnaîtront
dans ses terres avec de l'oussouet
l'allemagne et bien c'était qu'on se
réunisse tous pour montrer qu'elles ont
des clubs on a la classe et on fait des
gaves non six mois des loukoums et le
jour où ça ça sera bien fédérer on sera
un mouvement très très pénibles changera
les moeurs à ce moment là on bosse là
dessus mais pas une veste à fois une
veste qu'est ce qu'on fait en continu on
fourre son nez
vous trouvez un moyen falip ne pas payer
vos impôts qu'est ce que vous faites
moi ça me gêne mois de papier mais
maintenant les impôts c'est tendu ça bah
oui parce que ça paye des écoles et des
routes et aux annonceurs et des routes
qui traversent des écoles en plus soit
ça c'est scandaleux ça c'est pas
terrible et impose un parc autre côté
pourquoi même par exemple pour boisset
sa dangereuse comme c'est vrai vous
voyez david douillet frapper un enfant
pour lui piquer des pièces jaunes
qu'est-ce que
vous faites bon le tabasse avec lui mais
on traite une fois que l'enfant est vrai
c'est l'animé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais ça l'est
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les gens
je lui dis sans
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tout vrai tout le monde va y aller un
jaune mais on essaie laurentienne vraie
belle comédie familiale et il s'est dit
génial de voir tous ces mondes rigoler
là et on me fait une avant première à 10
heures on a fait une avant première à 10
heures et il y avait des enfants cinq
salles pleines d'enfants c'est génial on
est très très contents et fiers de notre
plein de bonbons si exacte et festive
potentiel pardon je suis et moi je sais
pas ce qui m'a pris je sais pas
peut-être excusez moi je prendrai les
militants à témoin du président pas
comme ça que je vais toujours trop doux
après bon droit mais roland lhomme ville
a dit voilà